valley religiöse dimension music at dort
rüber unterhalte ich mich jetzt mit dem
organist und dirigent rudolf lutz
[Musik]
rudolf lotz organisches lutz instrument
wo klang von größe und erhabenheit
erzeugt pro flöte die magische
instrument wo sanft die sehnsuchtsvolle
klang erzeugt wir hassen das zweite ort
unterschiedlich instrument beides
religiös spirituellen empfindungen
erzeugen als organist eine möglichkeit
aber mit der registrierung die
verschiedenen klangfarben die
verschiedenen gefühl überhaupt jetzt ac
mailands kleinz wird wer an gott ist
schon das erhabene an ihre grosse regel
strich braucht so genannte plan aber ich
hätte auch noch als register dörfle die
vier fuhr
das klingt das so
ich hätte aber auch ein andere krankheit
finden zum beispiel ca
oder ganzen heller klagen
da wäre zum beispiel das schlagen der
flügel der einst elvis also ich kann als
maler als polnische rolle und bis zum
ausdruck bringen was ich nicht als
religiöses gefühl beispiels wie es da
steht und was bereits als religiös das
park in worte fassen das ist frau dass
sie die hoffnung sie mir doch als
religiöses gefühl und ich versuche das
denn auf der orgel darstellen
hoffnung gibt frauen nämlich dunkle
farbe vidal 16 förster sind
ich probiere einklang finden wo weich
ist und wir machen es wie spiel
[Musik]
sicherlich eine aufstiegen die basslinie
k juni stieg die hoffnung auf die hat
und wie es genau dort strukturierung
durst tempel und das gefühl zum ausdruck
bringen sind es jetzt vor allem klar
bestimmte rooney sind da in der
klosterkirche in fischen oder sind es
bestimmt die komposition wirkliche
religiöse gefühl erzeugen also wird
alles was sich hinter der ruhm sich laut
akustik danach halten denn wieder
kompositionen die art und ließ wenig
gestalte wenn es erfreulich systematisch
den schnellen intensiven blut wir vorher
treffen kinder still und natürlich jene
bestimmte stil audi möglichkeiten das
darzustellen ohne eigene möchte jetzt
wenn wir in der bibelgeschichte lassen
oder auch in anderen heiligen texten den
erzeugt das immer stimmt die
erinnerungskultur und ich weiß sie sind
seit knapp 40 jahren leiter vom
singkreis und singend mit älteren
menschen
was jetzt das mit blick auf sich ich
glaube das ist das geheimnis zum erfolg
von heutigen nachmittag wenn ich
verliere fordert seit jahrzehnten hat
und erlebt die guten und die schlechten
zeiten
denn nachher hängt sie an dass wir
gewinnen aber patina drei personalien
zum beispiel unser
[Musik]
8 oder auslandsreise jetzt aber celox
ohnehin und quält und seid aber mit dem
und so weiter und so fort
erinnerungskultur über jahrzehnte bringt
ein energien
wo sich einst als sicherheit darstelle
und vielleicht hilft wenn man eine
gebrochene beziehung zum global head die
transzendentale obdachlosigkeit und
überbrücken
mein großvater hat mit mir knackt im
keller ohne und die täter so geschmeckt
aber weil die größten erhält migov mit
auf dauer klein und mache erinnert
wenn ich da wieder schmeckt sofort an
der großelterlichen keller und ich
glaube es ist ganz ähnlich mit dem
militär liiert waren das level an
gesundheit in bösen und in guten zeiten
ist mehr als nur ein schönes lehrt
sparallianz oderflut ganz herzlichen
dank für das schöne spruch wir sind in
der tat ganz dicken hand hätte zweite
advent und ich glaube grundklang ich
darf uns auch weiterhin durch die zeit
begleitet ich wünsche ihnen ganz schöne
zweite wahl
[Musik]